foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
LDN control the advice you started
number three engine on Cosmic girl
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
estimated ldlc on control I'm going to
take over the PTZ camera while we do
take off how do I roll out or takeoff
[Music]
LDN control room nice to me please
repeat I'm going to take over the PTZ
camera for takeoff and roll for takeoff
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone and I appreciate
you sticking with us as I give you
another pronunciation and Linguistics
lesson on the difference between
Australian pronunciation and American
um we're actually going to take a look
at our flight path now quick MCC update
we are go for takeoff that was just
called about 30 seconds ago so we're
going to bring our graphic up that shows
the actual flight path that Cosmic girl
will take after she takes off from
Spaceport Cornwall
once that's come off you'll see that
you'll track over the water there taking
off in a Westerly Direction out towards
Ireland and is going very close to a
County's Kerry and cork then she'll take
a left-hand turn and go into what we
call our race track and as you can see
it's aptly named because of the shape we
do two passes in the race track the
first one is the cold pass and that's
essentially where we're doing a lot of
checks on the aircraft the rocket the
prevailing winds and the weather and
then we go into what we call our hot
pass and that's where launcher one goes
onto its own battery power and switches
to autonomous mode when we're getting
very close to the drop point our Pilots
will pull into the aircraft pull-up
maneuver you'll hear on the MCC audio
the words release release that will come
from the pilots the rockable drop on its
way to space and Cosmic girl will come
home to Cornwall a special shout out to
our airspace support in this region of
the world from the UK and from Euro
control as well as authorities in
Ireland Portugal Spain and France stay
with us we'll be back in a moment
and let's have a little bit of a chat
about who's on board Cosmic girl today
we're so lucky to have two pilots and
two launching Engineers who are
incredibly talented and well-versed in
Cosmic girl and this incredible launch
that we're about to see we'll talk about
our two pilots first we have Matthew
standard or Sani as he likes to be known
our RAF test pilot who's on secondment
from the RAF over to Virgin orbit
joining him in the cockpit is Chief
pilot Eric bickert the two of them are
incredible team and we know they're
going to do an amazing job for us
tonight up above the Atlantic Ocean
joining them in the back we have two
launch Engineers we have Dale Alexander
and we also have Bryce Shaffer
um these four have been amazing we've
really got to know them here in Cornwall
they've been doing test flights around
the county as well as getting into the
schools and really inspiring the local
school children about maybe becoming a
pilot or a launch engineer or working
with rockets so the whole Community is
definitely cheering them on down here in
Cornwall tonight
I think we'll leave it there for a
moment and we'll watch Cosmic girl as
she hopefully starts to make her way
around the Airfield
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
as you can see on our visuals right now
Cosmic girl is taxiing uh like I had
said earlier we had cleared all of our
launch commit criteria and cleared to
take off our crew ground crew had
cleared the area
and our Pilots are ready for a takeoff
so we're just positioning ourselves for
wheels up still planned in the next
minute or two
as Natalie had said earlier this is our
second nighttime takeoff our last
mission was also a night time
and some folks in the area of Cornwall
and also the counties I mentioned
earlier in the South part of Ireland may
have noticed in the last couple of weeks
Cosmic girl making some practice runs
out there off the coast
Cosmic girl is now on the runway taking
off
the ground but Speed Launcher one
godspeed Cosmic girl or on this historic
with European and UK mission to open
space for everyone
as I mentioned earlier on the flight
path description because of people will
now Bank to the left
and take the route which is
approximately west southwest
LD Radiohead on control room has been
unlocked acquired a new key
required a new key
up until the disconnects a few minutes
ago the data or the data that you had
seen coming through any of our graphical
user interfaces was coming through a
umbilical connection to our ground
support equipment one of the things that
makes us special as a launch provider is
our agility and we'll talk a little bit
more about that later that the bulk of
our ground support equipment is mobile
meaning that some of the new aircraft we
have purchased here at virgin Hall but
being cargo aircraft we can load a
couple of rockets plus all of the ground
support which include our
Rocket Fuel and our liquid oxygen
conditioning ground support equipment
can be loaded on the aircraft itself and
then transported to whichever Runway can
support a 747 so we unload the Rockets
we meet the payloads to the front
usually through a special clean room
that has been set up we also have a
mobile print clean room that we can
bring to different launch sites
then it's attached to the rocket and
that can be done either inside a clean
room or while it's still attached under
the wing of cosmic girl and we've done
that a couple of times on recent
missions where we essentially back up
the payload conditioning trailer to
cosmica while she is attached underwear
with a larger one and then done the
connection there
so the idea is that we can fly to your
port or your airport your Spaceport land
roll out our ground support equipment
our payload processor facility do the
work over a few days connect up to your
facilities and then take off
launch the rocket come back to the base
and then fly to the next port
[Music]
you can see on the graphical user
interface here
all of our temperatures and pressures
remain to be nominal some of the more
interesting stuff you'll see is now down
at the bottom of the screen where the
cosmicol panel shows that she's
currently a little over 300 miles per
hour and steadily climbing just gone
past 12 000 feet
Cosmic girl of course like any other
aircraft is captained and that means
that the captain on board in the cockpit
is the person that is the authority on
the vehicle so there may be some slight
changes to altitude climbing or the
trajectory that cosmagirl uses to move
out to the racetrack and that's up to
the captain but generally what we expect
to see here is that when we're in the
racetrack for the cold pass we'll be at
approximately a little over 35
000 feet
[Music]
foreign
mentioned the data coming through
earlier through an umbilical once we had
disconnected from that it trailer that's
sitting on the tarmac next to Cosmic
girl all of our data is being streamed
through RF link so radio frequency link
so they're essentially a type of Wi-Fi
our aircraft has that so our rocket data
will come up to the aircraft and then
the aircraft can transmit back to the
ground and you can see the live data
that you see here on the GUI
once the rocket is dropped it has its
own s-band transmitter it's a relatively
um tried and true technology s-band
that's the same technology that streamed
the photos of the initial Apollo moon
landing through the parks radio
telescope in New South Wales Australia
back before I was born but that will be
transmitting to multiple ground stations
that are across the globe as we fly out
trajectory to orbit we will show some
graphics a little later in the program
that show the trajectory of the rocket
today as well as the ground stations
that we'll be tracking her as she works
her way to release the payloads
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow that was amazing I had to step out
and see that with my own eyes so thank
you Chris that was so informative as
well I'm absolutely buzzing that was
huge and now we can't wait for for
rocket launch I'm now joined in the
studio by a good friend Steve Isley who
is vice president of Business
Development from Virgin orbit hi hey you
know yeah I mean what an exciting day
and I'm really pleased to introduce the
Secretary of State Grant shops who's in
charge of the department for business
energy and Industrial strategy leading
an economy-wide transformation by
backing Enterprise and unleashing the UK
as a science superpower through
Innovation uh Grant thank you so much
for being with us here on this historic
day you've really been instrumental in
helping bring launch to the UK and
supporting the industry you probably
know this is actually the first of
course historic launch from UK soil and
also historic launch from Western Europe
uh tell our viewers what is this day
what is the
the yeah another very excited about the
uh launch and I mean this is something
which we've been working on for more
than a decade now uh as you rightly say
um the UK tonight will become the first
country uh to launch uh satellites from
European uh soil
um and that's been that's been a a long
process involving a lot of folks not
just at virgin but uh throughout our
space sector which employs about 47 000
people
um it's much bigger than most people
realize the other thing people possibly
don't know is that more satellites are
produced in the UK anywhere outside of
California so so we're begins abusing
particularly the smaller and the Nano
satellites the type that virgin orbit
put into space and so to see these nine
go up finally this evening
um it's extremely exciting and we're
we're delighted to have back this launch
and um Cornwall could be one of of seven
spaceports um springing up throughout
the UK so we were excited to see this
one and others developing
and you mentioned uh some of the
industry here in the UK so how do you
think this and future launches will
really help Propel the space ecosystem
in the UK including jobs and what makes
the UK such a greater destination
been set yeah I mean
anything
the top of the the 10 o'clock news here
on the on the BBC and I see they were
giving this a mention and saying that
the uh the the the the satellites are
being launched right now it it brings
people's attention to it so if you're a
youngster and you're watching this
tonight or you're catching up on it
tomorrow you'll be understanding that
space launches are something that
happened from uh from the UK I think
that's incredibly important it brings
more people into the business you ask
the sensible question of why the UK well
it happens that particularly for the
type of satellites which are
increasingly getting launched a lot of
these smaller satellites they've gone
from about one percent of the market to
11 uh we think that over the next decade
or so uh there'll be huge opportunities
probably about 15 billion pounds worth
of launches of these smaller satellites
the UK happens to have uh the right
um location in other words
geographically we've got the right
science with uh what is it seven of the
world's top 20 uh universities uh and
we've got the right industry combined
with government to help all of those
things Stack Up and ensure these
launches can happen and I know that from
personal experience because both of my
current job as business secretary but
also my previous job as the transport
sector I've tracked and worked on this
launch I've been down to to Newquay and
Cornwall I actually brought over the
rocket for the uh the GE
um seven last year uh to uh to Cornwall
so so we uh so we've had a lot of you
know to get these things going you have
to have a lot of different elements come
together regulatory scientific industry
uh government all working in in Tandem
and that's the thing the UK's got going
for
and you know I know we know that uh you
have a strong uh love for Science and
and uh part of your platform is making
Britain a a really a science superpower
how do you see space launch and this uh
ecosystem developing in Cornwall
contributing to that
wait I look it's it's hugely important
to that I was just looking across the
kind of list of you know the payloads
tonight you know there there are uh a
whole variety of different satellites so
you've got Amber one that's a satellite
that's built in Glasgow you've got from
acs2 that's the satellite built in
Hampshire you've got space Forge a
satellite that's built in Cardiff so you
see as I go around the country here
every part of the country every part of
the United Kingdom has got a link to
what's going on in Cornwall tonight and
that's incredibly incredibly important
exciting but as I mentioned before uh
not to take any away anything away from
Virgin orbit because you guys have got
there first with this unique launch
system that has so many benefits but we
have a number of vertical
um space ports uh being built uh and
being planned so seven in in total and
I'm expecting to see versical launch
from Scotland for example possibly later
this year or or next year so uh this is
an exciting time it's worth a lot of
jobs not jobs in in Cornwall there
perhaps 250 or so but actually across
the country uh in in the thousands and
the tens of thousands
um that you know making the UK a great
place to do space yeah and you mentioned
some of the payloads uh I uh on this
Mission and there are some first I mean
there's the first Welsh satellite the
first Omani satellite
um so there's a real also International
flavor in space how important is it uh
one for the UK to have its own launch
and end-to-end sustainable space-based
capability vis-a-vis other space-faring
nations so as a nation leading in the
space realm and uh two really
International Partnerships I mean I know
that this is important for UK you
mentioned the other launchers but
clearly space is an international uh
Cooperative uh industry and so working
across country lines is equally
important
that that is absolutely true and and
just in uh the awesome we
um signed a deal essentially with the
European Space Agency we
um put in uh I think the figure Springs
to mind is over 1.8 billion pounds uh
We've secured three more British
astronauts so we're working in the
international sphere so in Europe but
also with NASA and a whole variety and
have historically done so kind of
interestingly though you ask a really
interesting question because
um the UK is the only country in the
world to more than 50 years ago have
design built and launched uh its own
rockets and satellites successfully into
space and then scratched the entire
launch program and this was back in 1971
it's a long time ago now uh it was kind
of a surprising thing to do uh given
many other countries or other other
locations continued or or have got into
the Space Race since then I think the
big thing that's changed is the
commercialization of of space ever since
though because I was just looking back
you only have to go back to 2019 and
there are only about 500 satellites
launched globally but in 2021 so just a
couple of years later there were 1900
satellites launched so you can see this
is a massively growing Market
particularly particularly these smaller
Nano satellites some of which are no
bigger than a shoebox that the United
Kingdom really has great specialty in as
well as some of the bigger ones which
we've always tear so there's a big
market and we want to work globally we
want to do that but we also think that
we can grab probably as much as as 30
percent of the launch launch market on
these on these smaller satellites which
is something we're very keen to do I
think that's absolutely right I mean the
UK has all the pieces to the puzzle
you've got all the satellite
manufacturers you've got incredible
universities you have the logistics and
now you have the launch capability uh so
really you have this end-to-end uh
sustainable space applications Mission
capability that is unrivaled practically
for the small settlement Market in
particular and definitely joining the
other few Nations that actually have
their own launch capabilities so I I
think really that we're pleased to you
know be your partner on this journey and
help make that a reality
um maybe thanks very much you know it's
great to hear you say that because uh
but people folks won't know but we
generate about 16 and a half billion
pounds from uh space income each year in
this country and it's only set to to
grow and we're going to work
internationally to make that happen and
having this launch capability from
British soil uh clearly puts us front
and center of that
absolutely and uh finally I think you
know so people know that you're a pilot
yourself so as you know captive carries
happening or Pilots are going on on this
journey going forward
um you know
maybe you could talk a little bit about
your experience as a pilot just what's
going through your mind like what is
what is your mental state right now and
uh how exciting is this for the people
that are really on the front lines here
of this launch well you know I you know
obviously I offered virgin orbit the
opportunity to use me as the pilot uh
and say this just okay uh I look I think
everybody everyone who who flies
everyone with a pilot's license knows
that the thing that you're always doing
before a flight is you going through uh
the pre-flight checks in your mind and
then after that you go through the whole
sequence of thinking through the flight
I visualize the flights that I that I
take uh in advance and I know that the
the captain will be doing uh exactly
that incredibly experienced RAF pilot
um uh flying the uh the aircraft this
evening uh who would have run through
this has done it of course in reality as
well so it's not just a sort of in
principle thing uh and that
visualization I always find as a pilot
really helps the process of flying and
of course on a mission as important as
this I know that is that the work that
would have been going on in advance
yeah and we're we're of course rooting
for our Pilots we're rooting for
engineers we're rooting for our team I
know the country is behind this Mission
we're excited to be here in the UK uh
Grant in the few seconds we have left is
there anything else you'd like to uh
tell our viewers maybe about this
Mission or about some other insights
some parting words if you will
well look when I came down to uh new
team we brought over
um the rocket last year actually it was
a replica of the rocket last year
um some people said to me at the time
this is all fine but actually is this
just a static display is it really going
to happen is it really going to happen
from the UK and you know collectively
and you guys in particular have proved
that the answers definitively yes the
aircrafts in the sky I think in what
does that in 4C 8 minutes or so we're
looking for uh the drop
um and uh so you know I just want to say
a big thank you to everyone and it's now
thousands of people who've been involved
in getting this Mission uh up and
running there were any number of things
which could have stopped it and the
first time you do something particularly
from somewhere new uh you know there are
lots of regulatory barriers to overcome
I actually want to express my thanks to
my Irish counterpart who I spoke to and
helped clear the airspace to the
Portuguese and many others who've been
involved in this this evening but look I
think this is amazingly exciting time uh
this uh we're all we're all eyes glued
to the uh to the drop uh and the launch
of these satellites and well done to you
folks uh for for making this happen uh
and uh and tonight all eyes are on the
United Kingdom launching these
satellites
all right Secretary of State Grant
Sharps thank you so much again for your
continued support thank you for your
leadership uh and we look forward to
continuing the partnership
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back everyone this is sometimes
thought of as kind of the more quiet
part of our mission obviously we haven't
dropped the rocket yet when we light
that candle things are going to happen
very very quickly for those that have
been watching our GUI you can see that
all of our fuels are nominal but one
thing that we are watching Keeping a
close eye on is our payload adapter
fairing temperature
during the climb uh the aircraft right
now is at I believe just over 30 000
feet which is nominal and during the
climb we were moving through the clouds
and the storm cell one thing we like to
do during our captive carry is actually
do a little thin wiggle to make sure
that if there is any icing that occurs
on the rocket during captive carry we're
able to break that away we detected no
icing during the captive carry up to
this point but we did that little
execution anyway and all that all worked
normal we are tracking uh normally I
keep saying nominal which is a good
thing we are tracking normally on our
flight path out towards the racetrack
right now we'll be back in a moment
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
hi everyone welcome back I have a very
special guest with us uh Colonel Davis
who is the director of the office of
space launch at the nro and uh Colonel
Davis is joining us here today on behalf
of one of the payloads that is flying uh
with the launch today and so we're
really excited to have you thanks for
joining us
yeah thanks for the opportunity it's
absolutely great to be here and play a
small role in this truly historic launch
so when you and your colleagues heard
about at the narrow first heard about
the possibility of launching out of the
UK what did you think
yeah it was uh absolute excitement
um you know since the the very existence
of uh the nro started over 60 years ago
we've really taken great pride in
um you know how Innovative how we like
to advance the the state of the art and
the Art of the possibility when it comes
to operating in space this is was just
really another one of the those
opportunities to do something brand new
to do something exciting and that's all
really truly in our DNA
and so of course I mean there are other
launch sites historic launch sites in
the USA uh like Cape Canaveral
Vandenberg what do you see is the value
of having additional launch sites in
particular out of the United States
yeah the anytime that we can go to any
different launch site any different
launch capability that adds diversity to
the portfolio of launch solutions that
we as the nro launch providers are able
to give our customer set that enables
them to be able to not hinder what
they're doing with their Technologies
and really opens up the aperture
for for more advancement and more
ability to do what we need to do in
space
and so uh do you see then there being
potential advantage or value to that to
geographical spread particularly when
you think about launching
internationally oh no doubt again and
that's just again the diversity uh that
we're talking about and anytime that
we're not committed to any one or two
launch sites
um that just uh it it enables us to do
different things to do better things uh
from wherever we need to do
absolutely and uh yeah we agree we think
there's uh definitely uh different
opportunities to provide access to
different orbits and uh and Mission
capabilities uh internationally so uh
moving to another topic uh there's that
phrase responsive launch response to
space uh and you know it's pretty
exciting uh term and the National
Security World in particular what do
those terms mean to you and uh you know
how is that important to uh your mission
you have responsive launch from my
perspective is really being able to be
responsive to my satellite customers
needs to be able to deliver a launch
solution when they need it where they
need it how they need it
unconstrained so having vertical launch
having horizontal launch all of those
things uh you know add additional
toolbox ads ads to my toolkit right that
I can take to my customer set yeah
absolutely and then of course launch On
Demand potentially would be a whole
other benefit within a 24-hour period or
so which is something virgin orbit is
trying to accomplish
um so another question would be a lot of
what you and your nro colleagues have
talked about when discussing this
mission in particular is the value of
the partnership I think the
international partnership in particular
with the UK RAF uh with all that's going
on in the world and in space right now
both in the areas of conflict and times
a piece what do you see as the start of
international Partnerships and
interoperability between the U.S UK and
potentially other partners what are
those benefits there yeah you absolutely
nailed it the agility partnership and
interoperability were the the three big
things for us with this Mission you
talked about partnership and
interoperability there no doubt you know
when if you look at the logo for this
Mission it screams partnership you've
got intro U.S space force U.S UK space
agency RAF you the list goes on and on
and on not to mention our industry
Partners
um so yeah partnership was a key part of
this entire mission for us and then you
know as as launch folks we like talking
about the launch but but we don't exist
unless we put capability on orbit right
and as the primary Rideshare for this
Mission you know we're here I have a job
to get capability on orbit and with
these primary payloads that we're
working with UK the UK mod and dstl
that's the whole goal is to be able to
demonstrate our Allied interoperability
with that data sharing across our
partners in this as you mentioned
incredibly Dynamic and quite frankly
dangerous space environment that we're
dealing with today so you definitely see
that you know this type of partnership
is something that will be valued going
forward and more such missions will
likely be accomplished then in the
future
well yeah I mean anytime uh
who knows what tomorrow looks like right
um but again anytime I can provide uh
unique Solutions any any other kind of
launch solutions to my customer stuff
that's attractive to them
um so yeah we certainly hope to this has
been a fan the the Cornwall Community
here uh the Cornwall Spaceport the the
new key Community have just been
absolutely fantastic you know we were in
a taxi
um the last time we were down here and
they were like oh are you out here for
the launch That's so exciting it's you
know the community is just really
embracing and it's fun to be a part of
that yeah exactly I mean especially
being a historical first year I mean it
really means something to be part of it
so it is you can feel that excitement
you know whether it's in the taxi cab or
at the launch site uh and then finally
uh the other major element of the
partnership that often gets discussed is
between government and Commercial
industry how is the ability to leverage
commercial industry in particular and in
order to tap into new capability
abilities change the way that you and
your colleagues work and think about
missions well and it enables us to
really unlock the Innovation
um you know that we are all about
advancing technology and innovating
Nobody Does that better more efficiently
quicker than the commercial environment
so anytime that we're on the government
side are able to put constructs in place
like the contract that we use to acquire
this particular launch service that
really harnesses the energy and the
power that's in that commercial industry
so we can work together better and
ultimately Advance our U.S and Allied
capabilities yeah I can agree more of
course on the commercial side but uh I
mean and we likewise appreciate the
Partnerships with government entities
that are also encouraging and supporting
new technologies to come to the market
so it definitely is you you know it's a
symbiotic relationship that that I think
Fosters and supports both sides so uh
Colonel Dave's really been a pleasure
having you here today and we thank you
for coming down to Cornwall uh do you
have any uh final thoughts or words
you'd like to say as we uh uh get ready
for the launch yeah I just again thank
you uh thanks to Mel who's been the host
most of today on this uh who her and her
team
um and then the Virgin orbit and virgin
orbit National systems teams have just
been fantastic to partner with on this
particular Mission and and I personally
have been uh really proud to just play a
small role in it so thanks very much
thank you
all right back to you guys
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone as you can see
from the data that we're just showing on
our graphical user interface all of our
levels are still nominal we're watching
as I had mentioned earlier watching that
payload adapter temperature but that is
still doing totally fine for this phase
of the flight for those folks that have
been watching our 3D map which we'll
bring up now you'll notice that we did
fly just south of the county of cork in
Ireland we've taken our left hand turn
and now we're in our race track that I
had mentioned earlier so we'll be moving
into our coal pass in just a moment we
are still on track for our previously
advertised drop time
um so yeah stay with us
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone uh you already
heard about the Prometheus payload that
is one of our payloads that we're taking
space today I want to tell you a little
bit more about a few more of the ride
shares that we have on board first one
there is the iod-3 Amber or commonly
known as the IOD which is developed by
the satellite applications catapult and
Horizon Technologies and is built by AAC
client-spaced all based in the United
Kingdom
IOD 3 is expected to be the first of
more than 20 Amber satellites to provide
space-based Maritime domain awareness
data to users
another one is Circ or the coordinated
ionospheric reconstruction cubesat
experiment and it's a part of a joint
Mission between the UK's defense Science
and Technology laboratory and the U.S
naval research laboratory
third one there is Dover which is
developed by the Rhea group of Belgium
and it's the company's first satellite
in its 30-year history we're very proud
to be carrying her on board today and is
being co-funded through the European
space agency's navigation program and
built by open Cosmos of the United
Kingdom
Dover is a small set that was created as
a Pathfinder for resilient Global
navigation satellite systems
we're going to bring up the GUI again
just a couple of notes from the MCC our
launch commit criteria for terminal
count has been given the all clear the
terminal count as the portion when the
rocket goes into an autonomous mode we
did have some questions on the YouTube
stream that I want to address some folks
saying this is actually the second
launch after Wallace and Gromit went to
the moon for cheese thank you very much
for that but and also the use of
Fahrenheit versus Celsius typically in
Aerospace world we use Imperial units
over metric units
um
I think that's all I got for the moment
uh like I said we're moving into the
cold pass and things are about to get
very exciting so please stay with us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the moment we've all been waiting for is
about to come but before that we want to
talk a little bit about the mission name
Start Me Up which is named after the
iconic British Rock band's record Start
Me Up that was released by Virgin
Records in 1981. I can't think of a
better name for the mission for a
starting up launch out of the UK but
let's hear a little bit more from a
familiar face Sir Richard Branson Start
Me Up I can't think of a more perfect
name for Virgin Orbit's first launch
from Spaceport Cornwall then the UK's
first launch and the start of an
important and exciting new capability
I first heard the Rolling Stones when I
was at school and their songs have been
in my head ever since
as a nervous teenager armored the tape
recorder bigger than me I interviewed
Mick Jagger for student magazine
and years later we tried to sign the
band and years after that we finally
managed to bring the stones to Virgin
records and they helped make us the
biggest independent record label in the
world
I remember hearing Keith Richards
kickoff Start Me Up When We promoted the
Stone's comeback tour in 2012.
a decade on they've still going strong
and I've loved spending time with them
over the years even if Ronnie Wood beats
me at poker and Paul
one of the most wonderful parts of
Virgin Orbit's missions has been the
opportunity to bring the Virgin family
together not least by honoring a voting
records artists with each launch
and this should be the most thrilling
one yet congratulations and good luck to
all involved in this launch in Cornwall
the UK and worldwide like the song says
once we started up we will never stop
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back just a quick update from
the MCC as you can see on the the screen
right now we have made it through our
coal pass and we're now working through
the hot pass the counter on the left
hand side is a little bit of a misnomer
because it's really drop already time
and I also did want to mention you
probably saw a quick uh camera feed that
we had where the screen looked black
that's actually nominal because that was
a live Camry feed from the camera that's
actually on the rocket underneath the
payload fairing
um you can see now this is an aft camera
view from the drop so we have it looks
to be a successful ignition of the stage
one engine uh as we make our way to
space
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
like I had said before a lot happens
very quickly after drop you can see here
that we're actually getting towards the
end of our stage one burn everything is
nominal so far we've had our pitch up on
the bottom uh on the burn time on the
graphical user interface if you do have
that one off we have made it through Max
Q Alpha which is one of the most
stressful physical
moments for the rocket very comfortably
through Max q and then also through our
maximum heat aerodynamic heat Heating
we have made it through Miko our main
engine cutoff that is our Newton three
engine engine shutdown is reported as
nominal
and if we can go back to our aft camera
varying brake wire is broken
we have stage separation
you may see dropouts in the data during
the flight here that is expected as
we're switching between the different
ground stations that are picking up the
signal from the rocket
switching data sources
now as you can see the trajectory that's
being shown on the screen is no longer
of cosmic girl because she is on her way
back to
Spaceport Cornwall in the UK the
trajectory is Now tracking launcher one
as she makes the way down to phenomenal
Atlantic
um ocean uh towards the Canary Islands
stage two trajectory nominal
stage 2 it's directly nominal that means
our flight path is as expected being
picked up by those ground stations where
probably almost coming up on halfway
through our stage two burn number one
on the GUI here you can see in the
center there obviously the cool flame
coming out the left-hand side but you
can see the fuel and the oxygen leaving
the stage as it goes through the engine
another really neat thing to see is the
gimbal over on the left hand side the
the blue square with the dot in the
middle shows you the position of the
engine as as it is steering stage one
stage two burn nominal
altitude now is looking at around about
six hundred thousand feet
approximately three miles per second
bus voltages for the batteries and
nominal you may have noticed that we had
a lower voltage while we're in capacity
because the power was being provided by
Cosmic girl at that point before we
switched over to the Rocket's internal
batteries
stage 2 burn is a little longer than the
stage one burn so this might take a
little while for us to get to second
engine cut off one
foreign
as I said earlier there are points of
the
flight where we don't have the Telemetry
coming from the rocket because we are
out of view of the ground stations uh
our flight software folks have
implemented a storm forward on our
rocket which means that when we are out
of view of the ground stations we are
storing that data so that the next time
we do come in view our ground station we
can download it and uh from Target like
from Madrid
data source switch to Madrid
Madrid ground station has locked on to
our rocket and is streaming the data now
confirmed signal from math problem is
switching to an entry source to mass
Palomas
Newton 4 shot down initiated
you just heard the call for Newton four
shutdown Newton four is our stage two
engine
so that is the completion of the first
burn of our second stage
you can see along the bottom of the
screen right now our flight timeline has
been updated to show the cosmic girl is
returning obviously and then launcher
one which takes up the majority of the
flight timeline there it is at our S2
cutoff for our second stage engine
cutoff
foreign
so now's probably a good time to talk a
little bit about our rocket profile like
I said once we get to drop a lot of
stuff happens very very quickly what you
might have seen is initially after the
drop around about five seconds or so
after the drop because we need to make
sure that our aircraft is safe and out
of the way we fire what we call our
propellant settling thrusters or our
psts and their solid rocket boosters are
on the back of launcher one and they
give the the rocket a little push
forward to settle our propellants
for stage one and then we have that main
engine start or mes for S1
and then you saw over I think it was
about three minutes or so our stage one
burn which as I had said before does
most of the heavy lifting and our main
engine cut off separated from stage two
and stage two has to do the work for the
rest of the journey
we start our second stage engine which
is the burn that just happened then
during that burn we separate our
fairings and what that does it opens up
the pointy end of the rocket essentially
through uh Ordnance firing that opens up
that section and exposes the payloads
we continue to fly under power on our
second stage during that first burn and
then we'll have that cut off and you can
see the graphic on the screen right now
we again get to the coast which is the
phase that we're in right now
and we do a maneuver we execute a
maneuver called the barbecue roll so
essentially we are we are rifling
through the atmosphere and what this
does is it avoids one side of the the
stage from getting too hot and the other
from getting too cold our rocket is
covered in a spray-on foam insulator but
this is a very standard maneuver
procedure that that most rocket
companies execute
a second engine start so
ses2 so we restart our second stage
engine to lift us a little more and then
we'll cut off that engine and after that
will be our payload separation
and that's when we can start popping
champagne corks and dancing
after payload separation we do have a
couple of extra things that we want to
do here during this Mission and we will
do a a maneuver called the c-cam or the
contamination and collision avoidance
maneuver and then we will actually fire
our second stage for a third time so
you'll hear calls for SES or a second
engine start three and then Seco or
second engine cut off three once that's
complete we go into a phase that we call
safing and then the mission is complete
okay
you can see images on screen right now
from our mission control center over in
Cornwall the UK
take a moment to say how much we
appreciate the folks that came out to
Cornwall this evening to watch our
launch it is a historic day obviously
for the United Kingdom but for Eastern
Europe as well and we we very much
appreciate you all being here today
including those folks that have joined
us on the live stream uh through YouTube
thank you for being here and and being
part of this journey with us
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
changing traffic light to Green
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
controls on copy go ahead
have you let the tower know that
hazardous operations have ended uh no I
have not and I cannot but I can
coordinate with range one on fa in it
copy also did you change the traffic
light no I did not
sorry we're going to Green
is it green now let me double let me
pull up the is it it's okay LC is
working it okay copy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone this is of course
the least interesting part of the flight
we are in S2 Coast so there's not a lot
happening and you're not probably
hearing a lot of audio come from a
mission control center but I did want to
let you know that Cosmic girl is only
minutes away from Landing that is our
primary mission is safety here at virgin
orbit and we want to ensure that our
flight crew and all the folks on the
ground are ultimately safe at All Phases
of our mission so yeah just a quick
update here from the MCC we'll be back
with more in a moment
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone it appears that
launcher one has suffered an anomaly
which will prevent us from making orbit
for this Mission we are looking at the
information and data that we have gotten
and we'll be back with you in a moment
with more
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back as we see Cosmic girl
touching down back to UK Spaceport
Cornwall she did a magnificent job today
and was fully successful in her portion
of the mission as I had said earlier
version one virgin Orbit's number one
priority is the safety of our flight
crew and the folks on the ground as well
so we can see that she has come home
safely
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back and thanks for sticking
with us for this long everyone we have
experienced anomaly and we are gathering
more information I did want to take this
opportunity to thank our customers our
virgin orbit team Von s uh UK Spaceport
Cornwall of course and our BSL
interpreters over in the UK we're going
to be ending our live stream at this
point but please be sure to check out
our other channels our social media
channels for more information as soon as
it's available
thank you
[Music]